computed axial tomography
also known as a cat or ct scan
takes x-ray imaging a step further by
creating a three-dimensional picture of
the human body
from a series of two-dimensional x-ray
scans
it works like this a patient generally
lies on a flat bed that passes through
the hollow middle of a device that looks
like a giant square donut
a scanning apparatus rotates around the
patient aiming spirals of
x-ray beams at whatever section of the
body is being scanned
as the x-rays pass through the body they
are absorbed or weakened at different
levels depending on the tissues they
encounter
the result is a series of images and
shadows that create an impression of
bone and soft tissue
sophisticated computer software
interprets the x-ray shadows from many
angles producing a three-dimensional
image of a cross-section of the body